okay so let's go into some more details
on Cloud endpoints you probably remember
this picture from lesson to where we
introduced Cloud endpoints and where we
describe this capability to create one
API that you could use to create client
applications for many different devices
well you may wonder now why is Cloud
endpoints and it different from a pure
HTTP protocol for example a REST API
well let's look at that when using Cloud
endpoints it allows the development
environment to inspect and be aware of
your API and this has multiple values
first of all application design when
designing your back-end application you
can focus on the high-level application
design and you don't need to think about
low level communication syntax and
semantics Cloud endpoints also performs
native client library generation for a
number of different languages this helps
out greatly with a number of different
things for example communication and
establishing connectivity and error
management so you don't have to deal
with low level communication errors but
also higher level functions such as user
authentication that we use for
conference central and also since your
API can be expected Google can provide
many tools around it the API Explorer is
just one example of such a tool which is
extremely useful so Cloud endpoints is a
great way to develop api's that are
rock-solid easy to use portable across
devices and languages and can be used
with tools such as the API Explorer
great value here in other words since it
lets you focus on your app and let
Google take care of all the low-level
details let's now look at Cloud
endpoints in your development
environment